una parte
[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy nos
acompaña el doctor carlos eduardo pérez
médico infectólogo de la universidad
nacional de colombia y asesor científico
de france 24 en español doctor gracias
por estar con nosotros en france 24
hablemos ahora de la situación
epidemiológica en eeuu porque los cdc en
ese país se autorizará con usar
mascarilla a los vacunados en ciertas
circunstancias significa eso entonces
doctor que los que están vacunados no
contagian y tampoco se pueden contagiar
lo que el cs raúl y menciona es que se
pueden retomar algunas actividades
básicas en las personas completamente
vacunadas y que su entorno esté
completamente vacunado actividades como
las reuniones familiares como entidades
en fuera y fuera en el aire libre pero
que su entorno esté vacunado puede
hacerse razonablemente sin el uso de la
mascarilla eso porque se logra porque
tienen ya más de un 60% de personas que
han recibido al menos una dosis y un 40
45 por ciento con segunda dosis quiere
decir que la tasa de vacunación es muy
alta y les permite hacer alguna
flexibilización en el uso de las
mascarillas ahora doctor porque esto se
llama asegurando por ejemplo entonces
las mascarillas en aviones en sitios muy
cerrados transporte público
porque ahí no hay la certidumbre de que
todos estén vacunados entonces en un
viaje en un avión en un transporte
público pueden haber personas que estén
o no vacunas o que estén o no enfermas y
en ese momento pues debe usarse las
medidas de protección como las que hemos
seguido la situación de eeuu no es la
situación que estamos viviendo en
nuestra región y podemos por eso debemos
tomarlo con cautela puede ser que suceda
en un futuro pero en este momento todos
debemos mantener nuestras medidas de
protección mientras cada uno de sus
países lo hacen de acuerdo a su dinámica
aquí biológica y entonces diciendo eso
le pregunto a qué porcentaje de
vacunación se debe llegar para alcanzar
la inmunidad de rebaño
recordemos que la inmunidad de rebaño es
una inmunidad que se hace colectivamente
entre el 70 y 80 por ciento de la
población para que el virus impida una
transmisión pandémica pero pueden seguir
pasando que hayan enfermo las personas
que no se han vacunado esta inmunidad
cerebral es con la totalidad de la
población del 70 80 por ciento no con el
70 80 por ciento una localidad de un
país o de un barrio entonces debemos
masificar la vacunación para lograr esa
inmunidad y frenar la pandemia doctor
todo indica que los países ricos vacunan
mucho más pero en la mayor parte del
mundo el ritmo es mucho más lento por la
inequidad y la capacidad de adquisición
de las vacunas hay docenas de países que
ni siquiera han recibido una que pasa si
los países ricos alcanzan la inmunidad y
el resto del mundo se demora muchísimo
más
la fe y la fragilidad de las estrategias
multilaterales está demostrada esta
estrategia coachs podría ser la que
predomine para que estos países que no
han iniciado la vacunación lleguen a la
vacunación y los países que tienen
excedentes de vacunas como está
claramente mostrado lo hagan us a través
de estas áreas multilaterales y que
todas las personas logran acceder porque
porque no importa si un país lograr su
vacunación en el 70 80 por ciento con la
migración humana los viajes
internacionales las dinámicas
poblacionales las personas van a tener
ingreso de nuevos casos y de nuevos
linajes que haría perder la efectiva de
la vacuna
aquí nos tenemos que concientizar que la
vacunación es para todos no para algunos
y que las estrategias multilaterales se
deben fortalecer los los países que
tienen excedentes de vacunas deben
fortalecer las tácticas multilaterales y
todos debemos propender porque se vacune
la mayoría del 70 por ciento del mundo
incluyendo niños y adolescentes
recuerden eso así es de autor y además
también la organización mundial de las
aseguró nuevamente que el mundo no está
listo para que se reanuden como a lo
mejor antes lo hacíamos los viajes
internacionales precisamente por lo que
usted dijo porque hay muchos países
avanzados en esta inmunización y hay
otros que ni siquiera han recibido una
vacuna entonces realmente no se podría
hacer mucho en cuanto a una inmunidad de
rebaño hablando de todo el planeta en
conjunto doctor muchísimas gracias como
siempre por su tiempo por estar aquí con
nosotros en france 24 ustedes también
gracias por acompañarnos siempre hasta
una próxima oportunidad feliz resto de
ella
[Música]